hey this is presh talwalkar
a horse is tied to an outside corner of
a 20 foot by 10 foot rectangular barn
what is the maximum area the horse can
graze outside the barn
if the rope has length l
solve for the cases of l equals 5 feet
and l equals 25 feet
you should find the exact answer
if you are up for a challenge solve for
the case of l equals 50 feet
you can solve for the answer to three
decimal places
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
we'll get started with the case of l
equals five feet
the horse can graze all distances that
are five feet from the corner of the
barn
if you sketch out the shape this turns
out to be three quarters of a circle
with the radius of five
so the maximum area that the horse can
graze will be three quarters of a circle
with the radius of five
the area of a circle is pi r squared and
if we substitute in r equals five we get
the area is equal to 75 pi divided by 4
which is approximately 58.905
feet squared
now let's tackle the next case of l
equals 25 feet
the problem starts out similarly where
the horse can graze a three-quarter
circle
where the radius is equal to the length
of the rope
but in this case there is a difference
the horse actually has leftover rope
after walking along one side of the barn
so when the horse is going along the
side of the barn that has 10 feet
there's actually 15 feet of rope left
over so the horse can graze another
quarter circle around this wall of the
barn
similarly for the barn which has a
20-foot wall there will be five feet of
rope left over so the horse can graze
another quarter circle of five feet
around this corner of the barn
the maximum area that the horse can
graze
will be the sum of these three different
shapes
the area will equal to be
the area of three quarters of a circle
with a radius of 25
one quarter of an area of a circle with
radius 15 and one quarter of a circle
with a radius of five
we can use the formula for the area of a
circle
and find out that this simplifies to be
2125 pi divided by four which is
approximately
1668
feet squared
so now let's tackle the more challenging
case of l equals 50 feet
the problem starts out just like the
case of l equals 25 where we have three
quarter circle and there will be
leftover rope for each side of the barn
but now let's look at the length that's
left over around each of the walls of
the barn so for the wall which has 10
feet
there will be 40 feet of rope left over
so the horse can graze 40 feet around
this wall and there will still be
leftover rope but it will actually be
covered in another case which i'm going
to show you
so for the wall which has 20 feet there
will be 30 feet of rope left over
and now the horse can graze a quarter
circle around this with a radius of 30.
so this is why i didn't draw out the
rest of that 40 foot radius it's because
it's actually going to overlap with an
the other quarter circle
with the radius of 30.
and now we end up with a very sort of
difficult shape because the area that
the horse can graze is not simply the
sum of circles and quarter circles
we end up with a part of the grazing
area that will overlap
so in order to find the total area we're
going to have to account for this
portion that overlaps
i'm going to show you two different ways
to solve this problem
one way will be to approach it using
calculus we're going to directly solve
for the area of the overlap
the other way we're going to use
trigonometry and we're going to solve
for the rest of this area by cutting it
up into different shapes where there's
no
overlap so let's start out first by
considering the overlap directly
we could consider the area by adding up
the areas of these quarter circles and
three quarter circles and then
subtracting out this little area that
overlaps
so in order to do that i'm going to
magnify these quarter circles and look
at this region which overlaps
so in order to use calculus we're going
to put a coordinate system
i'll put the origin right where the barn
intersects the
uh circle with the radius of 40.
so the circle with the radius of 40 has
an equation of x squared plus y squared
equals 40. its center is at the origin
and it has a radius of 40.
we can solve this equation for y
we get the square root of 1600 minus x
squared
the other circle
with the radius of 30 this has a center
that's 20 feet to the right and 10 feet
down
so the equation of this circle will be x
minus 20 squared plus y plus 10 squared
equals 30 squared
we can solve this for y
to figure out the equation of this
circle
so in order to solve for the area of the
overlapping region we're going to need
to know where these two circles
intersect
we can figure that out by setting the
two equations for these two circles
equal to each other
we can then solve this equation to get
that x is equal to 24
plus 4 times the square root of 11.
so now we're going to calculate directly
the area of this overlapping region
so we'll focus just on this overlapping
region
it begins at the value of x equals 20.
the first portion
where we go up to x equals 24 plus 4
square root of 11
this will correspond
to the circle with the radius of 30.
so we know the equation for the circle
and so that's going to be the y value up
to this limit
we then will want to consider the rest
of this region where we go up to x
equals 40.
the boundary of the shape here will
correspond to the boundary of the circle
with the radius of 40.
so for the remainder we're going to have
y equals the square root of 1600 minus x
squared
so we've now figured out all the key
details so that we can set up two
integrals which directly calculate the
area
we have the area of the overlapping
region
being
the different limits that we've
calculated
and the different functions which we've
calculated
so you can put this in a numerical
solver and we'll get that this is
approximately 341.7794
square feet
so we figured out the hard part of this
problem
we can now go back to our original
diagram
we can calculate that the the area that
the horse can graze
as the area of these different
three-quarter circles and quarter
circles minus the area of the
overlapping region
we've just calculated the area of the
overlapping region and then we go ahead
and substitute in our values for the
area of these quarter circles and
three-quarter circles
and we end up with an answer that the
area that the horse can graze is
approximately
7512.202 square feet
so this is the approach to solve this
problem using calculus
i'm now going to show you a different
approach which uses trigonometry
it'll be quite involved but i'm going to
show you that it's actually possible to
do it without calculus
so let's go through those steps
we'll focus on the region that overlaps
so instead of worrying about this region
which overlaps we're actually going to
dissect this region into different
shapes that don't overlap
the trick
is to connect the corners of the barn
to the point at which these two circles
intersect
we end up forming a kite-shaped
quadrilateral
now the region above this kite shape
quadrilateral is the sector of a circle
the region below this quadrilateral is
also the sector of a circle
so we can actually get rid of these
quarter circles that we've drawn and we
can see that we can calculate this
entire region
by calculating the area of three
different non-overlapping
non-intersecting shapes
or sorry they are intersecting shape but
they're not overlapping
so now it remains to calculate
the area of these three different shapes
so we'll start out with the area of this
quadrilateral
the trick is we're going to connect the
diagonal
of the rectangular barn
this will form a triangle
so we've connected a triangle
to the quadrilateral to create a bigger
triangle
so we calculate the area of the
quadrilateral by taking the area of a
larger rectangle and then subtracting
the area of a right triangle
so we'll start by calculating that
the diagonal of the rectangular barn is
equal to 10 square root of 5. we can
calculate this because we know the two
legs of this right triangle and then we
can use the pythagorean theorem to
figure out the diagonal
so we'll input that as one of the values
to this triangular shape we know the
other lengths because they're equal to
the radiuses of these two different
circles
we can also put in the values for the
legs of this right triangle
so we now have a triangle where we know
three of its sides and we can calculate
its area using herron's formula
the value of s here is equal to the
semi-perimeter it's one-half the
perimeter of this triangle
so we can substitute in the values for
these known legs lengths of the triangle
and we end up with the area of this
triangle is equal to 100 times the
square root of 11.
we then have the right triangle we can
calculate its area as one half times of
its base times its height
so this is equal to one hundred
so we figured out the area of this
quadrilateral
is equal to one hundred square root of
eleven minus one hundred
it now remains to calculate the area of
these circular sectors
and in order to do that we need to know
what the central angle of each of these
sectors is
so we'll go ahead and start calculating
some angles
we'll start out with the rectangular
barn and we'll consider the right
triangle we'll consider the lower right
triangle
so we can calculate this angle over here
because we know in a right triangle
we've got the legs calculated as 10 and
20 and we know the hypotenuse is 10
square root of 5.
so we can use trigonometry to figure out
this
angle and we use trigonometry to figure
out this other angle we have the inverse
cosine of square root of 5 over 5 and
the other angles the inverse cosine of 2
square root of 5 divided by 5.
we now need to calculate the angles in
the large rectangle which consists of
the quadrilateral plus one half of the
rectangular bar
so how can we do that
well recall from before that we've
calculated the three lengths of the
different sides
if you know the lengths of three sides
of a triangle you can calculate
the angles of the each of the triangle
of the angles in the triangle by using
the law of cosines
so using this formula and using the
known lengths of these sides we can then
calculate the two different angles
that we need in this calculation
so these will also be the inverse cosine
of something complicated
so why do we do this it's so that now we
can calculate the angles of these
circular sectors
so we can calculate the angle of the re
of the circular sector
where the radius is 40 as equaling 180
degrees which is pi radians
minus
the inverse cosine
where we get rid of the
angle from the big triangle and then
minus the other angle from the right
triangle of the bar so we've taken the
entire 180 degrees and we subtracted out
the other angles so that leaves us with
the angle of this circular sector that
we need to know
we can do the same thing for the
circular sector where the radius is 30.
we take the pi radians which is a
straight line and we subtract out the
angles of the two triangles
which are not part of the circular
sector
so we end up with a complicated
expression but we can do this
so now we just need to use the formula
for the circular the area of a circular
sector this will equal to the radius
squared times the central angle divided
by two
we know the radius of each of these
sectors and we've just figured out the
angles
so we can go ahead and substitute in the
values that we have
we'll get approximate answers and we can
put this all together that we figured
out the area that work we want to know
these three shapes
all together
is approximately 1621.716
so now we go back
to the problem that we don't know the
area that the horse can graze
so this will be the three quarter
circles with the radius of 50 plus the
rest of the area that we just calculated
so we put that all in and we again get
to the answer of approximately
75.1 75 12.20
square feet which is exactly the same
answer as the calculus method although
it took a little more
involved calculations we could figure it
out without calculus
did you figure out this
problem thanks for watching this video
please subscribe to my channel i make
videos on math and game theory you can
catch them on my blog mind your
decisions which you can follow on
facebook google plus and patreon you can
catch me on social media at
preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description